lena dunham reveals she wishes she had
an abortion and later apologizes for it
the 30 year old actress opened up about
the stigma surrounding abortion and
being pro-choice on her latest women of
the hour podcast when she recalled her
own abortion story about when she
visited a Planned Parenthood in Texas
bang quote even I'd the woman who cares
as much as anybody about a woman's right
to choose felt it was important that
people know that I was unblemished in
this department Elena went on to say
that that was the moment she realized
she was encouraging the stigma against
abortion instead of fighting it and then
said quote I can say that I still
haven't had an abortion but I wish I had
the girls star explained if she had gone
through the experience like her mother
and some of her best friends she would
better relate to them to which she
received a ton of backlash and later
took to Instagram to apologize for what
she referred to as a distasteful joke
honestly I feel like I made the right
decision Lena posted a pic of the word
choice on a chalkboard along with a
statement that read in part i take
reproductive choice in america more
seriously than i take literally anything
and therefore own full responsibility
for any words i speak that don't convey
this clearly
you